pressure on officials across the country
to keep schools open and expanding
in-person learning
that's because some states are now
allowing teachers to get the covid
vaccine but unions across the country
notably in cities like chicago have
fiercely resisted a return to the
classrooms
will the vaccine and the stalemate to
get everyone back in the classroom in
wisconsin
teachers are going to get it starting
next week in new york starts on monday
the february 28th in colorado
daegan this seems to be good news
because we kids i know are not
are not nearly as vulnerable as adults
they have they get it they beat it
99.9 of the time teachers were the issue
why aren't teachers scrambling to get
back in front of the classrooms
because they have the complete inability
to think of the kids first and not
themselves and it's disgraceful what has
happened with these teachers unions
even mayor bill de blasio said yeah
when he starts making sense look out he
said the safest place in new york city
is our public schools he said this last
week
as the city's positively positivity rate
inches toward nine percent the schools
are well below one percent
over and over again you've heard from
say the national academies of science
engineering and medicine
saying with you have to have in-person
instruction
for kids it hurts them the lack of
interaction
even adolescence get them back
in school and put the unions back on
their heels
mayor lightfoot of chicago one is uh
really kind of touring
she's giving parents the option of
sending their children back to school in
person
but so far these teachers do not want to
show up fewer than 60 percent of the
roughly 2 000 teachers are coming in
the people that are hurt are low-income
kids who don't have the infrastructure
to even do the remote learning which is
not as effective
agreed one hundred percent uh it's best
to get those kids back in school you
have to be aware
of course of their health but i mean
once you start getting the vaccinations
what is stopping i mean the more quickly
that people get the vaccinations the
better
and the more people that get it the
better uh so to me this
is like a no-brainer i i understand that
kids can potentially still be spreaders
but that's not been proven to be a big
issue here
and what we do know is what you
articulated brian that those kids
especially low-income kids
are the ones who are just you know they
don't have the support at home
if the parents are out working a job or
two come home late right
the kids there all day with the computer
it's just very difficult so
i think that you got to have a change of
attitude i understand the safety
precautions by the way new york city
elementary schools are open
yeah and by the way dana i'm torn some
of my best friends
in this world are teachers and they do
such an outstanding job and you don't do
it for the money
you do it because you love kids and
giving back and that feeling of of great
of
raising great people or playing a role
in that so where do you stand on this
so i think that there are a lot of
teachers who want to go back to the
classroom and i think that
the unions don't represent them well
it's one of the reasons that you've seen
remember that lawsuit that the supreme
court ruled that you don't have to
give your donations to the union um
unions all across the board not just
teachers have seen
their memberships fall one of the things
this pandemic has done
is exposed the situation and given
parents this opening to say well wait a
minute why do we do it this way
if there are other alternatives why
don't we think about those
so it actually could be quite seismic
the changes i had a guy on the daily
briefing the other day named corey
deangelis from reason magazine
he said that the support for school
choice has gone way up and what that
basically means is
the taxpayer dollars that you pay for
your kid to go to school instead of
going to the school
district would go to you and then you as
a parent get to decide
right what to do with those funds to
send your kids
different whatever school you choose um
i think there's going to be a lot more
of that brian so
there might be light at the end of the
tunnel in addition to getting these
vaccines out
and so 90 billion uh jesse waters uh for
in california to get teachers
vaccinated they're all set to make this
uh covet friendly
this is odd because democratic mayors
and governors are taking on unions
they must be saying how did i get here
how do i get out of this
i'm just sick of democrat governors like
andrew cuomo blaming the feds for not
vaccinating enough people
i know states run their own health care
systems
they run medicare and medicaid they
administer
pretty much everything when it comes to
regulating hospitals regulating
state hospitals local hospitals they
have their own health and human services
department
i mean they run their own schools they
run their own elections
they have everything and they're
equipped to deliver the vaccine
who else would deliver the vaccine a
bureaucrat in washington dc
knows what's going on in suffolk county
no the county commissioner the mayor or
the governor knows what's going on in a
place
like suffolk county the feds gave andrew
cuomo nearly a million
doses and guess how many he's
administered
175 000 that's less than twenty percent
eighty percent of the operation warp
speed doses are sitting in freezers all
over new york state
that's a failure and if you can't do it
hire someone else
that's smarter than you to do it instead
of pointing fingers
and micromanaging this thing and as we
all know he'll have an opportunity to
include
this in the paperback version of his
book how to beat a pandemic
he'll include his failures which he
seems to have deleted or his editor
uh x dot all i could say is the kids
aren't learning at home i talk to more
students from
from 5th grade to 12th grade it's so
hard
a lot of them are just sitting there
with the answers to their tests on the
left and the test on their right
they're going to have to redo the
curriculum to make up for the damage
this pandemic has done
are they going to have to learn two
years at the same time and that's going
to put more pressure on the teachers